one of the most powerful men in las
vegas has died
las vegas sands ceo sheldon adelson
passed away last night after battling
non-hodgkin's lymphoma
adelson was 87 years old his funeral
will be held in
israel plans for memorial service here
in las vegas have not been announced
adelson was a self-made billionaire and
he leaves behind a huge legacy in the
gaming world not only here but over in
asia as well
he was also a major donor to the
republican party a philanthropist
and owner of the las vegas review
journal so what was
adelson's influence on modern day las
vegas and what is the legacy stretching
into the future
bianca holman spoke with a local gaming
historian for some perspective bianca
good afternoon
sheldon adelson owned the las vegas
sands corporation
those properties include the sands
convention center the palazzo the
venetian
and then you can see right here lit up
in front of the properties it says a
true visionary whose legacy lives on
at the venetian resort and around the
world and he had an incredible impact on
las vegas from casinos
to conventions his wife miriam adelson
and the las vegas fans both released
statements confirming his death last
night
just last week he announced he will be
stepping back from leading the las vegas
stands
to undergo more treatment adelson was
the son of jewish immigrants with the
relatively poor upbringing in boston
but over the course of his life he
created a number of businesses and grew
to become one of the world's richest men
he leaves behind a huge legacy in the
gaming world here in las vegas
china and singapore i think sheldon
adelson's legacy is going to be that
this is somebody who came to las vegas
and made a huge impact you know not just
in the gaming industry with his
properties
but also with his model the way he ran
them also with his philanthropy and i
think for some people this is going to
be the model of what
people do adelson donated to unlv
the substance addiction center recovery
clinic the adelson addiction
recovery clinic and the adelson
education campus which is a jewish
day school now there are plans for a
memorial service here in las vegas
a date will be released soon reporting
from near
spring mountain and las vegas boulevard
bianca holman
8 news now thank